tous les cas c'est comme ça quoi il y a
des gens bien déjà moins bien
je sais pas si il marche bien je sais
pas où en bas
c'est l'important c'est de rêver
mais bon souvent c'est souvent on prend
on prend les rêves de
ce qu'on nous donne on nous donne pas
grand-chose pour nous amener à la
réflexion parce que c'est dangereux
d'amener les gens à réflexion pour pas
trop que les gens réfléchissent c'est
beaucoup plus facile de manipuler de
manipuler les gens quand ils
réfléchissent pas les emmener à la
réflexion c'est dangereux très dangereux
parce que s'il réfléchit ça perçoit que
c'est la merde quoi et la masse qui
s'aperçoit c'est la merde là c'est
dangereux